we're talking about and it specifically
even in that extended that intelligence
you're talking about government you're
talking about private industry academia
where it should the center of that
research live if there is a center I
think it's a good question I think that
MIT would argue it should be enough I
you know I think it's this this round is
quite shocking I think to the academics
because most of the money and the power
of the core Computer Sciences and big
companies and even open AI that some of
our friends made that was a non profit
and not inside an academic institution I
think is sort of surprising right yeah
historically would have probably been a
group of academics with the government
so this is a new thing but I feel like
as we start to emerge out of just the
computer science mode to how does this
affect society mode for for instance to
stake you know one of the areas that
we're really interested on justice
unbale and parole that's probably much
better to have a statistical AI
supporting the the judge but but then
it's not just about whether it's more
efficient you don't want to be judged by
machine right so so these as we start to
move out I think it'll be interesting so
who gets involved I think as you start
to get into the social sciences and the
law and the philosophy that becomes more
in government and academia but but it is
curiously and I think just we can't
compete are we academia can't compete
from the these guys are getting paid
millions of dollars at postdoc levels
they've got tremendous amount of
resources so so I think we have to kind
of assume now that but now the military
are talking about you know funding AI so
there may be another player that has a
lot of money but right now most of the
billion-dollar labs all of them are
really
in this look I mean we know the guys who
are funding them and you know if you
talk to Larry or others you know their
general attitude understandably is the
last thing we want as a bunch of
bureaucrats and you know that are
slowing us down here as we you know
chase the the unicorn at their heart of
the problem that we've seen is that our
general commitment as a society to basic
research has diminished our confidence
in collective action has been chipped
away partly because of ideology and
rhetoric and so if the notion is if it's
government it's bad and that's something
that I do think needs to be reversed
now that requires government to be more
nimble faster quicker smarter it's hard
in a big democracy with a lot of diverse
views sometimes to get it moving fast
enough in the direction that something
like AI is moving it's moving so rapidly
that sometimes governments always
playing catch-up but you know the the
analogy that we still use 50 years later
when it comes to a great technological
achievement as a moonshot job and
somebody reminded me maybe Benham one of
you that the space program was 1/2 a
percent of GDP and that doesn't sound
like a lot point five percent of GDP but
in today's dollars that'd be eighty
billion dollars that we would be
spending annually on AI and right now
we're spending by less than a billion
that undoubtedly will accelerate but
part of what we're going to have to
understand
that if we want the values of a diverse
community represented in these
breakthrough technologies then
government funding has to be a part of
it if government is not part of
financing it then understandably those
who pay the piper call the tune and all
the issues that Joe is raised about the
values embedded in these technologies
end up being potentially lost or at
least not properly debated you bring up
a really interesting tension there that
Joey you've written about that idea of
innovation happening on the margins or
at the edges and then with the space
program and NASA really is centrally
governed that how does that relationship
change this this kind of development and
thinking about where the the
transmission of those ideas can happen
well I want to emphasize that the way we
now think about crowd wisdom essentially
and a bunch of experiments everywhere I
I think that can accelerate rather than
impede progress as long as everybody's
linked together with a sense of common
purpose and responsibility and
accountability just to give a very
concrete example part of our project in
precision medicine is to gather a big
enough database of human genomes from a
diverse enough set of Americans all
kinds of racial types ethnic types body
types you name it gender that instead of
financing medical research where we give
the money to Stanford or Harvard or some
other school and they've got their
samples and they're hoarding them and
they're working on it and it's a very
linear process you know now have this
entire database that everybody has
access to
and the potential to short-circuit the
the research process before you've got
promising candidates for treatment you
know can be hugely accelerated because
people aren't all holding on to their
stuff and now that's the power of the
Internet that's the power of
connectivity and the networked world
that we live in what I've tried to
emphasize though is is that just because
the government is is financing it and
and helping to collect the data it
doesn't mean that we hoard it or only
the military has it or it's got to be a
top-down approach but there does have to
be some common set of values of a common
architecture to make sure that the
research is shared by people that it's
not monetized by one group rather than
another and there has to be some core
principles that we all agree to and
that's I think an appropriate role that
some group like NIH for example can play
and I think that if you look at the
moonshot a lot of the value or the tools
that were created in order to do that or
if you look at CERN they've got some
esoteric physics problem but they invent
the web while they're at it and and so I
think these mega projects bring together
an interdisciplinary group to solve a
problem and so that's really interesting
and I think one of the problems with
standard peer-reviewed government
funding is it goes out in this kind of
hierarchical pattern that's very
politically correct and very rigorous
but it doesn't really get these big
ideas going and I would say the other
thing that you have that you're doing
well is the open data initiative right
so when you're talking about AI you need
data
the government has data and I helped
start a non-profit in Japan after
Fukushima to get citizens to collect
data on radiation measurements we have
53 million of them we did well and so we
came to Washington DC and we did a
workshop we didn't buy the apipa EPA
guys and the NSS and then it says hey
guys and and they had all the data but
they hadn't it was open but it wasn't
published and we showed that and
actually there's data around the White
House that was cloud
like for national security they didn't
publish and we and we invited all those
guys and and our guys taught them how to
make the kits and they walked around and
measure the radiation around Jen as well
now that it's public we can really
sedate and what's now developed is just
a bunch of citizen science kids a lot of
them in Japan now working with the EPA
and that and then si in trying to figure
out how do you take radiation data
empower citizens and we're selling these
kids and these kits into high schools
and pivoting into to air and things like
that in what's interesting is if you get
kids that are sufficiently motivated the
kids on the edges and give them some
sort of interface to this data and I
think right now your agencies are
getting much more sort of inclusive and
and it used to be you talk to some
professor at some university and give
them limited access to the data right
but it turns out that that kids will
figure out how to use the data and right
now it's mostly visualization but once
we get AI a farmer may be able to go
direct you don't know collect the data
build a model and use AI to to do
something and that's just going to be a
lot of how tools get better but also how
the government interacts with those
people